[Laughter]
i just made it like really quick like
the other day
but yeah
well i was debating i was just kind of
this is how i overthink everything i was
like should i do the matinee
intro and then that or just that no just
that and then i was like well i think
we'll just do just that because
everybody's like fabulous
because it already says 13 o'clock
matinee presents yeah
okay i said damn you guys are prompted
well that's just because we're like
sitting here looking like in the final
minute so we're waiting what are you
guys doing when you because i'm looking
at somebody going in do you guys sit
there just listen to the damn music
sometimes i do that with some of the
people i uh listen to it's kind of
relaxing and they're kind of like intro
music the waiting music it starts to
become kind of like part of your daily
routine
to hear that [ __ ] i don't know why it
just kind of does
get into a routine pretty quick
but um
no that was a good intro
i liked that one that's the first time
i'd seen that she just whipped that up i
just well yeah i just made that like a
couple days ago because remember i said
when we because we first just started
doing this like last monday and then i
was like oh i should make a little intro
for that and then like i made it in like
seriously five minutes like on camera or
some [ __ ] i [ __ ]
got that lawnmower delivered today i had
to bust it it was up on a pallet i
couldn't get it off the pad i had to
break the pile apart that's okay
got it all it came with oil in it and
everything ready to go well they told me
it was it was you it's just starter oil
this and that but the owner's manual
says
it comes with summer weight oil just
check it that's good then run it
so i'm just running the [ __ ]
husqvarna oil that they gave me
and uh
that was a good mower man
fun big ass like tractor big orange
husqvarna
mower ty [ __ ] turns tight looks like
a damn tractor i'm driving that [ __ ]
around
[ __ ] people
neighbors going by waving going yeah cut
that [ __ ] you know [ __ ] i know what
they're playing lawn crews going by
looking at me
going oh you bought that piece of [ __ ]
okay and i just
got to drive it it was good didn't take
long
didn't take long now i'm going to trim
the hedges tomorrow
oh well but uh gotta do shirts tonight
send out three shirts
and um
we can mail out we're ready to mail out
right whey and mail out right from the
house yeah i got boxes i got envelopes i
got everything i got paper i got
all kind of [ __ ] okay i'll do the shirts
and uh we'll send them out send them out
tomorrow
and now camp guy you said you wanted two
extra ones but i didn't i don't remember
if you sent another super chat or not
so yeah you just he just said he paid
for two of them
but then he was like two more yeah okay
but i think the two that he said
initially were
uh
the canon one and the pliskin one okay
and then and you pay for those and then
yeah and then next dimension media they
wanted um a canon one okay but yeah so
they're making those three make those
three tonight and then i'll get them uh
sent off tomorrow
zack says you know uh i swear with the
haunting you could take the title from
any episode and switch them around and
lose nothing pretty much yeah yeah
generator i kind of yeah i kind of feel
like you know those little like uh you
know refrigerator
poem magnets where it's just like words
and you can like move them around and
stuff i kind of feel like they maybe
have that in in the haunting writer's
room where the lurking dwells
[Laughter]
where the dwelling lurks where the
dwelling looks
so lyrics and it dwells yes sir
seriously i mean you know you can dwell
on lurk at the same time those are not
mutually exclusive the weird thing about
it is that while i was researching this
episode um i also discovered that i'm
not sure if this is like in other
countries or if it's just like an
optional like an alternate title but i
saw that this episode was also called
hearing the dead sometimes okay that's
not what it was labeled
yeah well no i mean
most places say it's called where evil
lurks but i don't know if maybe it's
called hearing the dead like maybe in
the uk i don't really know well yeah i
just noticed that it was called that on
some
platforms wonder why they would change
the name of that episode doesn't
it maybe because uh it's the name of
something else that's copyrighted in
that country maybe a movie that's what i
mean yeah that's the only the generally
the only reason to change something that
innocuous is just like you know if
there's already something and they don't
want to get sued somebody's named that
already let's see how everybody's doing
veronica said i think there's a new
season of a haunting out that started in
late 2021 i had heard that it was coming
back
john smith said i'm making hot chocolate
i'm not rock and roll oh man that sounds
good
you know what next time i go to the
dollar general i should get another pack
of hot chocolate because i had like a
big pack of it but i used it all up the
whole thing because i love hot chocolate
i got a whole thing of quick downstairs
you do yeah oh i didn't five pounds a
quick i didn't know that makes sense
yeah yeah but not with water though yeah
yeah well i have the powdered milk yeah
i got all that neato and i also have
powdered or lots of it i mean it's
easier to just have the pack that
already has the milk and you just want a
roll you want you want convenience food
well yeah dog okay all right i just want
to make it over there like we didn't
heat up the water in my coffee pot i
don't want it to go downstairs i bought
a gallon
i bought a gallon of arizona iced tea it
came in a big old gallon and after i got
done with it was only like a dollar or
something if i got done with it i was
like man that jug that this came in is
worth about two dollars
if you'd bought it just without any
label on it you know what i mean like
tupperware says that's so i said [ __ ] it
i put it in a dishwasher and washed it
i've been making tea in it
yeah it's good too good tea
that is good tea i've already drank like
two glasses of it though so i don't want
to drink anymore but it's good it's got
like well he was using up all the tea
bags yeah from the house all these tea
bags so like some of them are peach and
some of them are cinnamon but it works
yeah i mixed them
right mixed them right and everything
and
did it in the water boiler you know from
the teapot the electric teapot did it in
there
and um then just was
stuck a funnel
in that clean
arizona iced tea container and
filled it right back up
got saccharine in there which uh you
know trying to keep the calories low
and it says there is and it's it's
printed arizona iced tea like
in color
it's not a it's not a uh
it's not a sticker you know it's like
it's like embossed in there somehow that
looks classy that's not arizona that's
my iced tea
yeah you know
well i think wasn't it i think it was
the diet arizona dude it was arizona
iced tea
uh zach says we're the lurking evils
[Laughter]
see so many titles they only need like
three words and they just switch them
around and already they've got like six
titles for some of these that's what
we'll see that's why i can't remember
whenever somebody says because a lot of
people said hey do where evil lurks and
i was kind of like i don't even remember
which one that is
um
so i had to like go look it up because
they're not other than the couple other
than the handful that actually had like
the location in it like a haunting in
georgia or whatever um yeah the other
ones are just like completely
and i obviously i remember demon child
because the man said i could because of
that horrible kid that tried to sit on
the kitty cat camp guys talking about
making sun tea just put it in there and
put it out of the sun yeah i remember
used to doing that yeah 70s you can't do
that anymore uh people have gotten
really sick because yeah it's uh people
are running around on top of those tea
leaves and over in indian [ __ ] and
people are [ __ ] taking pisses off
piss on them and stuff and then again
you got to have boiled water to help
sanitize it
those tea leaves are not
guaranteed to be cleaned
and there's also things like rats and
mice have run across those things
sometimes in
in uh long before they ever get to the
tea factory like out there in the farm
where they're growing it
sanitation isn't all that good out there
so
no man boil the water don't let it sun
tea you get [ __ ] what do they call
that [ __ ]
um
oh [ __ ] what's the name of that that's
just the samiasis i forgot the name of
it salmonella salmonella i think is what
it was i think it might have been
salmonella i mean maybe salmonella with
an e now get real [ __ ] sick from it
yeah
yeah veronica says google says season 11
started on december 31st 2021 on
discovery plus there you go got 11
seasons we've missed a bunch of seasons
they just started to suck but we will
look at them
yeah i mean i don't have discovery plus
but i don't think it's that expensive i
think can't you get it like as an add-on
maybe i can get it on as an add-on for
hulu or amazon maybe or amazon yeah and
it's just like another couple of bucks
yeah there's not an add-on for the
british yeah you got brit box and that's
only a couple bucks
but hulu has a bunch of add-ons too like
some of them i got for free like i got
hbo max for free because of my um
because of my phone plan like you got it
for free for that so yeah big enough
crowd let's go ahead and start
all right uh oh down the bottom said
there's a new btk documentary on netflix
about the cops who cracked the case that
actually might be good all right
uh yeah so this one's called um
where evil lurks i almost said we're
evil dwells again because now you're
confusing me yeah but it's like i said
like they're all interchangeable this is
called where evil lurks or sometimes
hearing the dead which i guess kind of
makes sense yeah that makes more sense
actually
it does well it's more specific yeah
more specific because the little boy
kept here a lot of people a lot of the
children started to hear dead people
trying to talk over each other scared i
don't think the adults ever heard that
did they
um
i don't know it's not real clear now i
will say that this had
less outside stuff than the last episode
we talked about but i did find a couple
of things
less info on it yeah i did find like a
little bit of like a diary slash blog
that the mom had written jamie shay like
right around when they were filming this
show
and um also there was a an article in
the arkansas
democrat uh
what the [ __ ] gazette yeah the name of
that newspaper
and there was an article about like it
came out in october of 2007 which i
think was about a month after this aired
and it was like a ghost hunter who
interviewed
the woman with the mom and then she went
there and like stayed in the house like
to see if she could find it so like
ghost hunters went there all right so
there was that so you you got all that
you read all that yeah yeah yeah
uh hey dave what's up here on a monday
it's monday right yeah yeah okay here on
a monday
so that's unusual but yeah a lot of
people seem to like these haunting ones
so like i said we're gonna start doing
every monday now
um so yeah so basically this is about
the shea family
now they move into a house in central
arkansas
interestingly i one thing i did find out
was that the show actually says pretty
sure he says markham arkansas yeah that
town does not exist as far as i'm aware
uh where it is actually is in lamar
arkansas that's where the house is the
house they used for the show
is near where the real one is but is not
the exact one so they did do another
like they did with the haunting in
florida where they used a house that was
nearby but is not the actual house but
yeah so it's actually in lamar and lamar
is not a real big town from at least
from its wikipedia page what i could
determine so if you wanted to find it
you probably could but i'm not telling
you to do that
uh okay so
here's how the episode goes
so they move into this house and it's
they love it because it's like super old
i think like the original part of it was
built like in the 1780s i want to say
and then it was added on to like in the
1800s
and they said it was in remarkably good
shape uh for how old it was so i guess
it had been kept up
and it ended up being like the location
being really good because i think it was
between like halfway between the husband
whose name was ben
and it's like halfway between his work
and his school because he was like
working as a nurse at night and then he
was going to school in the day still and
then she had a job too now they had like
a nanny or babysitter who came and like
looked after the kids because they had
three kids uh like a teenage-ish girl or
a tween her name was tori and then they
had a kid named bridger which is a weird
name uh the kid was like seven or eight
and then they had like a baby or a
toddler named jackson who was like you
know still a baby still in a crib
so uh so they move in and pretty much
the first thing that happens and this is
one of the unusual episodes even though
it has some of the haunting tropes that
dad works at night so you know so the
mom and kids are always there at night
by themselves that's always important
but this one kind of like bucks the
trend of having
the
you know wife and kids be the first ones
to see the ghost and then the dad
doesn't believe them actually the dad
sees the first thing or here's the first
one that's right
so he's pretty much on board from the
beginning which is nice to see and
actually they had like him talking on
there and he seemed like a nice man
actually they both sound seemed like
nice people i don't know if they're full
of crap or not but they seem nice enough
yeah and the actor they got playing the
guy does look a lot like him he does
actually they did a pretty good job they
did a good pretty good job with that
but he does seem like a nice man so
basically i think the first thing that
happened so like i said they get this
babysitter
and
uh so she stays in the house during the
day and the dad ben
he
you know he's uh works all night and
then he comes and then he sleeps until
like two in the afternoon and then he
goes to class
so he's sleeping in the house and they
have a baby monitor
and the baby monitor comes on and he
hears what he thinks is the baby jackson
crying and he's like wigging out because
he's like god damn it like whatever the
i can't remember what the babysitter's
name was but she's like what you know
get the baby you're supposed to like
keep the baby from making noise so the
dude could sleep or whatever and then he
gets up and he goes all around the house
the baby's not in the crib he's like
where the [ __ ] is everybody and he's
like calling there's nobody home uh the
babysitter has actually taken the baby
shopping so the baby isn't even in the
house
and ben hears a baby crying on the baby
monitor so that's a little weird
now this i think is the first thing that
happened so he doesn't really tell
anybody yeah he goes in there the
the the baby wasn't even there yeah
yeah yeah the lady the lady had taken
him shot and shopping that would freak
me out
that is pretty freaking it showed pretty
well they they portrayed it pretty uh
it was it was spooky in the episode this
was actually a good episode i forgot how
good this one was so it was like that
was a good uh recommendation real good
recommendation i mean this one
as far as just the episode it's it's
on par with like the original maybe a
little bit better of of uh
of um
amityville horror maybe more happened in
amityville but the suspense is about
like avenueville i liked it yeah a lot
more artistic than abbeyville you go
back and watch amityville man it's
[ __ ] really basic basic [ __ ] [ __ ]
movie but
it's kind of a testament to how
good these old series this old series
was
and this is watch it this one is horror
movie this one is also from season four
and just like the last one we did this
is season four episode six yeah
i like season one but season four was
strong
yeah yeah there's a lot of good ones in
season four actually so now we could say
like i said he didn't really want to
tell anybody i mean it'd be freaky but
you could probably if that was the only
thing that happened you could probably
like write it off as saying oh maybe
you're picking up interference from some
other baby monitor it does happen like
you can pick up radio stations and [ __ ]
like that like with the monitor so some
things do come out on that so he didn't
tell anybody about it right so they just
i don't know how long it was
after they moved in
now the next thing that happens at least
on the show is that the kid the the boy
bridger he starts hearing uh people
talking in his room
uh what he says sound like he can't tell
what they're saying and it sounds like
just a bunch of people talking over each
other
and it's kind of like freaking him out
that'd be spooky yeah and apparently the
older sister tori she hears it too
although again she doesn't tell the
little kid because she doesn't want to
scare him
but this one particular night uh at
least on the reenactment so he keeps
hearing that and he so he runs into his
mom's room he's like hey mom can i like
sleep in here with you because i keep
hearing all these voices and she's like
yeah fine
now tori wakes up too and hears all of
bridger's toys
like
like they're all on like little robots
and like sirens and all that kind of
[ __ ] and she's like what the [ __ ] is
that kid doing this she doesn't say that
she's like 12 years old but um she's
like what the [ __ ] is that kid doing in
there so she goes down the hall
and is like hey turn your toys off and
the kid's not in there because obviously
he went into the room and slept with his
mom so he's like okay so all the toys
are like moving around uh by himself
by themselves so it's a little creepy
so then some amount of time later jamie
the mom uh she hears what sounds like
the kids running up and down the stairs
uh she and actually in the real thing
that she wrote she said yeah she used to
hear that all the time sounded like i'm
running up and down the stairs or on the
upstairs hallway but then when she looks
no one is there and they're all asleep
and snoring
she comes back down to the kitchen and
the kitchen door apparently slams
clothes by itself which startles her and
then like creaks back open again by
itself and she doesn't see anybody
now at this point uh tori i guess tells
the mom hey i heard the baby on the baby
monitor when the baby wasn't here
and so jamie tells her husband that ben
and he admits finally he's like yeah i
heard that [ __ ] too that's pretty weird
and then like while they're talking
about that they both hear something that
sounds like she said it sounded like a
like a rubber ball bouncing down the
stairs very the changeling
um and he hears it too apparently so
again they think it's the kids like what
the [ __ ] are those kids doing it's late
at night but they go up and again
they're all asleep
so at this point um you know and i think
jamie said too that she always felt like
weirded out like watched oppressed that
kind of thing so it wasn't just these
couple little things apparently
so
they both are kind of like well maybe
the shit's haunted you know what i mean
and like i said i kind of like
because i kind of get annoyed with the
trope of
you know the wife and kids seeing all
the ghostly [ __ ] and then the husband
being like you guys are crazy there's
nothing going on so i like that they
kind of like inverted it with it with
this one where he's basically like yeah
this shit's haunted we like need to do
something about it you saw dave parker
was saying right yeah yeah i said okay i
said about it
zach says uh you guys i just finished a
load of laundry and i'm pretty sure i
forgot to put the detergent in
[Laughter]
i think i might have done that once
maybe once
i forget to put fabrics off and are in a
lot but i don't really care that much
about fabrics often yeah fabulous
doesn't make that it doesn't really make
it and it's all like goopy anyway
so we own it doesn't make a big
difference yeah i don't really care that
much about it
um
but yeah so at this point jamie goes to
the local library and starts checking
out a bunch of books about ghosts
now while she's checking it out like the
the nosy old lady who's the not even the
one that's checking her out but the one
like next to her
um she kind of like glances over like
hey what are you checking out i'm like
god nosey like none of your business but
you know what i mean but so she comes
over and she's like i couldn't help but
noticing all of these books you're
checking out you know i used to live in
a haunted house and it was super creepy
and blah blah and so then they talk and
it turns out it's the same house like
the older i mean this is a small town
like i said so the old librarian i guess
she grew up in the house where the shea
family lives now
and she said yeah it was totally haunted
um there was a little boy
that like the ghost of a little boy
that was there and they said well what
happened was like a long time ago this
little boy like fell out of one of the
upstairs windows and died and i guess he
haunts the place now
okay now
out of this episode this is the only
thing that kind of struck me as real odd
she's at the the library
checking out books
about supernaturals and hauntings and
then the librarian says you know i grew
up in a haunted house and then names the
house that she's living in now
it must be a real small town
well the actual town of lamar i looked
it up on wikipedia because i was trying
to figure out where this actually was
because i know sometimes they change the
name of the town which they did on this
as well
and actually a lot of the um
scenes they showed of arkansas were
actually not were actually like little
rock you know what i mean uh so we're
not the town that this is in the town
apparently only it's only about a
thousand people maybe like a little bit
more so that's like a pretty small town
although i think it is part of like a
larger metropolitan area so it might be
like a suburb okay type situation but
within the bounds of lamar it's only
about a thousand
people
from that part of the story
not that i saw like nobody like i said i
looked pretty hard like to see if there
was because i guess we lucked out with
the last episode that the lady that had
been at the center of the last one uh
dark what was it called dark wrath or
whatever they're all um yeah dark wrath
i think was the name of it um that she
had actually written a book
about her experiences and there was like
a lot of information about that book and
like i could read some of it online but
this one not so much there was like like
i said there was one article and the the
the lady the mom uh she had written like
a little like a diary blog post it was
like pretty short like when this came
out but that was pretty much all that i
found out about this place otherwise
um so you know it's just like i said i
don't it does seem really weird that
like you'd be at the library checking
books out and then somebody would come
over and be like
hey you know i used to live in a haunted
house but then i mean you'd have to talk
for a little while before it would come
to light
that it was a haunted house you know
what i mean well because i think they
showed that in the show because i think
she said oh i used you know i used to
live in a haunted house she said oh is
it around here yeah he goes yeah and
then she's like yeah it's this really
old house because i guess it in the town
it was kind of like a a well-known-ish
kind of house because it was really old
like it was the one of the older ones
that was still standing in that area i
think so maybe that's why like it was
rolled this yeah she knew what was
haunting it and everything or what she
thought she did yeah it goes with a
little boy because she said she grew up
there and like that it was a little boy
yeah
so
that's weird that would have freaked me
out
yeah that would be pretty weird if that
really happened in real life like yeah i
would be freaked out and uh
we can't confirm that there's not enough
data online but that's what the story
says that's what it says yeah so yeah
i'm just i'm like i said i'm just saying
what the what was on the episode and
that's possible probably a smaller town
and you know what i mean so yeah are you
going to run into people who lived in
there for a long time and lived in
several houses and
she put two and two together saw her
checking out books on the paranormal
says yeah i live in a haunted house
you know [ __ ] she gives the address
that's the one that she's living in the
other girls living in that's weird yeah
that would be pretty weird yeah
uh yeah so
yeah little boy fell out a window and
blah blah so
jamie kind of like asked the library
lady she's like well did it hurt anybody
and the lady's like no i never you know
it was creepy but like she's like he
never heard anybody so jamie gets home
and says to ben hey i rented this lady
at the library she used to live here and
she said like who the ghost was and she
said it never hurt anybody so ben's like
well that's okay then it's like i think
we can live with that if it's just like
the harmless little boy ghost uh so you
know that's they decide they're just
gonna continue on from there
but then
uh while she's at home and i guess ben
is at work or at class
she's in her office and she said that
she felt like this presence behind her
and then she sees
this evil
what's this demony fella
reflected in her computer monitor like
she sees it and then like she turns
around and it's gone right
uh this wigs are out as it would and so
she calls ben at work and he comes home
early now at this point i don't know how
much longer like how much later this was
but jamie goes back to the library
looking for that woman again
but this really like
the other [ __ ] woman at the library
i'm sure she wouldn't be [ __ ] in real
life but she's basically like oh she
doesn't work here anymore
and jamie's like well do you know where
she went or did she move away or what
the [ __ ] and the lady's like well i
can't give you that information you know
what i mean she was like girl she's like
real twaty about it so jamie's like well
gee thanks for nothing [ __ ] kind of
thing she didn't say that but you know
what i mean that's what she was thinking
murder horn is in there complaining he
had to throw all this 13 o'clock shirts
away or a lot of them because he's
spilling bleach on what the [ __ ] you
doing using bleach please bleach
i don't use bleach on anything maybe
sheets it's just the only thing i ever
bleach is kitchen towels yeah i don't
[ __ ] bleach things like those wet
kitchens white kitchen towels i bleached
them towels and
white sheets if you have white sheets
we have one set of white sheets and one
set of blue don't [ __ ] bleach away
you don't need bleach yeah
well i mean it's good for other things
but like i said it's good it's good for
if you have white kitchen towels you can
reach those
but that's all we use it for
um but yeah so the lady's gone which
like i said that's a little bit of a
plot thread they left dangle in there
it's like what happened to the library
lady like why did she take off i don't
know you think that she would at least
want to like
check back in with the after they had
this heart-to-heart conversation about
this haunted house you'd think but no so
she's never mentioned again
now a bit later this is pretty
horrifying okay then this apparently
really happened
so a bit later like i said i don't know
how much longer how much later this was
jamie is driving somewhere with tory in
the car and tori is in the back seat and
i guess they're coming from like she
picked her from school or something like
that
and they're in a horrible horrible car
accident
now the reenactment i don't know if this
is true because i don't remember if she
said this out loud but um the
reenactment showed that she saw like the
evil demony fella
in the street like it was a construction
zone like there was cones and [ __ ]
everywhere
and she
supposedly like saw this demony thing in
front of the car and it caused her to
like lose control of the car
uh tori the daughter who i think was
how old was she at the time she probably
she looked like 11 or 12 yeah
maybe yeah and so apparently the tory
was pinned underneath the car which i
think was an suv didn't she say it was
an suv she was like pinned under the car
and ended up breaking her back in three
places
yeah but didn't paralyze her luckily
yeah i mean they must it must have broke
just right because man that could have
gone really wrong well now at first like
they aren't actually sure if the if the
girl's gonna make it and then after like
she's like well she does pull through
but now it's like we're not sure if
she's ever gonna walk again
um but they're like okay well maybe
she'll be okay
uh you know eventually but she's in the
hospital they sit for two or three weeks
or something like that and then they
send her home but she's not gonna be
she's gonna be bedridden for like six
months or something like that um she
does eventually recover so you know she
could walk again and stuff but she was
very very lucky which they actually said
on there but yeah she broke her back in
three places that's pretty [ __ ] up
so she's kind of like has to sleep in
the living room they said that this
happened like not too long uh before
christmas time so they said it was kind
of a shitty christmas because they had
already bought tori like a scooter and
obviously she can't use it now because
she can't walk
at least for a short time so she was
just kind of like gee thanks you know
what i mean but you know so they said it
was like it was a real bummer
uh so at that point
bridger the little boy he starts
complaining again about the voices in
his room he calls them the bad boys
um and he said it's a bunch of voices
talking over one another and like i said
he can't understand what they're saying
so at this point uh bridger's in the
room with them and jamie and ben are
she's like look i don't like we can't
live like this i want to move
now ben says and again he doesn't fight
with her i was just like wow this is
really like nice because usually it's
just like to do we can't afford to move
what are you talking about you're crazy
but yeah he's just like he's like well
we can't move you know while tori is
still
you know convalescing because she can't
walk
but they're like we can start looking
now and then when she's walking again
then we can move so he does agree
doesn't argue with her or nothing like
that
now at this point bridger's in bed with
them and they kind of go to sleep jamie
feels something like flipping her hair
like she's laying like that on her side
and like something keeps going like that
and flipping her hair in her face and
she turns around to ben is like what the
[ __ ] like quit doing that to my hair and
he's like it's not me to touch your
[ __ ] hair and then like all hell
breaks these beds start shaking the
lights start flashing like [ __ ] starts
falling off the walls all kinds of stuff
so then they run downstairs and he said
they all sleep in the living room with
tori she's like i just wanted everybody
in the same room because i didn't know
what the [ __ ] was going on
so at that point they call the central
arkansas paranormal people like
investigative people
and uh they apparently look into the
history of the house and they said yeah
the story about the boy falling out the
window dying that's true uh so it's
possible that the the boy's haunted
house uh they also say that the
that the house used to be like some kind
it was like a um
uh like a way station carriage house or
like a train stop or something like that
it used to be something like that and
then for a time it was like a hotel too
uh one of the psychics because it's like
a it's a whole team they have like a you
know a researcher person and like an
audio visual person and then like they
have a mom and daughter psychic team i
guess
and uh they talked to both of them on
the show
and so one of the psychics the daughter
she sees the little boy and she sees a
[ __ ] load of other ghosts too and she
said they were super not happy about us
being there they were all like talking
and stuff and we just figured it was
ghosts of people that had been passing
through the house because it was you
know like a way station type house back
in the old days
uh but then she senses the evil presence
and senses that like all the other
ghosts are afraid of this thing whatever
the [ __ ] it is so then they do the ouija
board and at this point ben is like i
don't really believe in ouija boards i
thought this was a bunch of [ __ ] but
he's like so i didn't let the paranormal
team do it it was just like him and the
audio-visual guy and it's like you guys
just stand over there and ask questions
and we'll do it so we can like make sure
that we're not like moving it
so that's kind of what
that's what he did
uh so they do the ouija board and then
the evil
entity or whatever says that its name is
seth and he says they asked when were
you alive and he says never implying
that he's obviously a demon
and then they say like the planchette
goes nuts now you have to be like really
careful about this because i noted that
jamie when they interviewed her she said
the planchette went crazy like going in
figure eights
on the reenactment they showed that it
was doing it without anyone touching it
but she didn't specify that
she might have meant that they were
sitting there with their hands on it and
it started going crazy but in the in the
show they showed like no one was
touching it and it was doing all that by
itself so you really gotta watch because
sometimes
well and the thing about it too is that
later on when i read um the article with
jamie shay she's like i mean some of the
stuff she described they did show in the
show but she said some of the stuff they
exaggerated
um and some of the stuff like didn't
happen
so i'm just saying i just thought that
was interesting that she never said she
did say that the planchette went crazy
but she didn't say that no one was
touching it it may have been no one was
touching it but she didn't say that i
don't know if i buy it i mean you know
you guys know my story i saw one of the
best poltergeist [ __ ] cases i've ever
heard of the only thing you better be
enfield
there was all kinds of moving objects
but it's real hard to catch an object
move moving you'd catch an object
arriving falling bow
sometimes you'd see something come
flying in your direction but you
but
one time we saw a glass slide but that
could have been the condensation on the
bottom um
something thrown at you from a [ __ ]
direction where you weren't looking
nobody there
but never we were trying to catch it
actually moving something for a long
period of time you'd never
you'd never catch it
closest thing to some me catching
something moving was the rocking chair
going back and forth the stack of towels
on it
but as soon as i saw that i turned and
ran
and red was sitting there staring at it
for probably three seconds
but who knows maybe it was just rocking
because it had been pushed so it was
just residual energy
you know
yeah like something banged it
and it went like that it goes i don't
call it the poultry guys banged it and
it was rocking back and forth it seemed
like whatever had it still had it
so that's the closest
closest i i've ever seen to something
that's kind of like this planchette just
moving around like that
in my experience if you catch something
moving it's only going to be moving for
a few seconds then it stops
it's hard to tell exactly what happened
you know
like when the remote flew
you know yeah we saw it fly and hit the
ground and hurt it
i didn't see it pick up though no i
didn't either yeah i saw it when it was
already airborne it was already moving
right because like i said i wasn't
looking at it why would i right
it was like that over and over again and
people people have have uh but
poltergeist is different than haunting
people have commented
in books and and uh that i've read and
witnesses said that poultry guys seem to
have an amazing sense of timing
you know how could it have known you
weren't looking at it at that particular
second
my theory was it has to do with the
quantum physics it can't move it while
you're looking at it
it's got to be unobserved
and then it's free it's in the same
dimension that it's in that the energy
source is in
the bulger guys didn't it it moves it
and then it moves it into your field of
vision you see it but by then it doesn't
have a hold of it anymore
that's what it seemed like but it's hard
to tell man
and i was a kid when i saw it so
it's just memory now you know
yeah i'd like to explain it though it
has something to do with the quantum
physics
yeah so uh all right so the planchette
like i said whether or not people were
touching it but apparently it was going
crazy and uh it pointed toward a camera
because the paranormal team were there
and it set up the cameras and [ __ ] like
that
and
allegedly
allegedly
uh it pointed toward the camera almost
like hey look at that
and they said that they looked into the
camera and they saw
seth like the thing like they all saw it
conveniently they didn't show this video
uh if indeed it did record
so
that might have been one of the things
that she was talking about was
exaggerated i'm not really sure because
obviously they're not
serious is real good for this
they'll show you reenactments of the
photos and reenactments of the video but
not the actual material
yeah which that was paranormal witnesses
bag parallel no paranormal witness did
that yet but not
not a haunting which led me to always
believe that
the photographs and the videos that they
did have was were too weak we're not
yeah we're not that impressive not that
impressive because if it was super
impressive yeah they didn't want to
splash it all over the [ __ ] place
bluetooth dude says if i was a ghost i
would play your video games while you're
at work
eat all your [ __ ] out of your fridge
[ __ ] like that because you could be a
ghost and you could eat all you wanted
and not get fat but uh yeah so the
psychics do a house cleansing with the
sage and all that uh
nonsense and evidently they get rid of
seth they kind of like go through the
house chanting and burning the sage and
blah blah and then they supposedly drive
them out of the house and they do like
the circle of salt around the house and
all that uh that's supposed to be the
one looks like a grim reaper yeah he's
like the grim reaper yeah well and
actually yeah i think maybe that's why
this this episode is like so well uh
regarded is because of seth i think a
lot of people like remember seth being
real scary yeah he looked like a grim
reaper he does a little bit like the
grim reaper you don't really see him all
that good but you know what i mean
um so
apparently whatever it was that the
psychics did works they drove seth out
but they said they could let the other
ghosts stay because they weren't hurting
nothing
so apparently several months go by with
no activity
but then
one night bridger comes downstairs and
starts talking in a weird-ass voice like
he's possessed like
and then he kind of like his mom's like
what the [ __ ] kid like smacking him and
stuff and then he wakes up and he can't
remember how he got downstairs like how
did i get down here oh my god
so at that point like it's starting to
[ __ ] with their kids jamie and penn say
[ __ ] this [ __ ] and they run upstairs to
get tori who by this point has
completely recovered and she can walk
again and then apparently at least
according to the show jamie and tori and
i think jamie did say this that they saw
it in the hallway they see another demon
fella in the hallway like while they're
leaving now she did say that she saw it
in the hallway i don't know if tory did
or not but jamie says she's not
turns out that even though this
cleansing got rid of seth uh the place
still has a portal or some [ __ ] and i
guess like the psychics didn't think to
close it uh so another demon wandered in
as they do
so it's another demon yeah
so at this point the shay's know about
and they rent an apartment and they put
the house up for sale now another family
moves in
renting but i think they don't they
don't stay all that long now that's the
end of the show but i found out later
that
after renting the house to three
different families none of whom stayed
very long the shays actually in late
2007 moved back to that original house
because they had to for financial
reasons they were just like we couldn't
sell it and we couldn't get a renter to
stay
so they had to move back to it
they had actually moved out of state
they actually moved to joplin missouri
for a little while
but and rented the house out but they
said we couldn't you know we couldn't
get anybody to buy it and we couldn't
get anybody to rent it so they actually
uh moved back to it i don't know if they
still live there now because that was a
long time ago but they did actually move
back to that original house
so now i found something like i said
that jamie shay wrote back in 2007 like
right after the story aired on a
haunting for the first time
um
she basically said this is something
that she uh wrote to
one of the paranormal investigators
and she said this is then this is
actually her writing what
she experienced in the house she said we
hear footsteps up and down the stairs at
all hours of the night a ball bouncing
at 2 am when everyone is asleep we hear
a baby crying in an unplugged baby
monitor the doorbell goes off at random
times during the day yeah
i've had that happen yeah my good
natured dog barks ferociously at the air
this one didn't have a dog on it again
like just like the last one
uh my now they didn't show this on the
show um my husband and babysitter saw
the tail end of a victorian type dress
float up the stairs
um
my middle son has night terrors and
reports hearing voices to keep him up at
night a thin mist of smoke has been
spotted in the kitchen by both my
brother and me
at night when i'm just falling asleep i
feel a small hand stroking my hair and
footsteps running around my bed
my husband and i heard pounding on the
wall above the head of our bed just last
night door slam cabinets creep open
batteries drain in minutes i thought
you'd find this interesting at least
twice a week i find dimes stuffed in my
shoes and in my bed okay i know it
sounds funny but it's freaking us out
yeah
yeah uh she says i probably should
mention that our home was built in the
1800s was the original stagecoach stop
in lamar and it's rumored to have been a
speakeasy and maybe a jail at one time
there's a confederate civil war cemetery
on our land about 200 yards to the back
side of our house and an old thick rock
building that historians say was the
original kitchen
so she wrote that in
2007
and she also writes a little bit about
we just completed 12 hours of interviews
this was when they were recording for
the for haunting telling and retelling
our events to the director of the
discovery channel series
um they sat in there yeah they were in
joplin missouri like i said
uh they said yeah it took 12 hours and
then she said in a strange way i missed
that house yeah and then may 15 2007 she
writes the third set of renters have
officially moved out of our lamar house
the listing on our home expired with not
even a good bite from a potential buyer
renovations are nearly complete i want
my house back this time we will only put
good vibes into this house we'll rely on
god for comfort and protection we will
make it work financially we have no
choice so september 18th 2007 they moved
back in
uh and she said it's been a long time
ago now yeah she said it's been quiet
for the most part except for the
occasional stomp bounce creek thump and
the episodic blast of unexplained
musical scores from the next room
life is pretty normal
so you just hear a musical score coming
from the next room yeah what style of
music is it i don't know she didn't say
and like i said there was also an
article in the arkansas democrat gazette
gazette which came out right around
halloween of 2007 i think
and i'm seeing i'm trying i'm rereading
it again to see if there was anything
else interesting
that wasn't mentioned earlier this was
actually written by somebody that went
there and did like a ghost hunt and also
interviewed jamie shay
um they were talking about how active
the place was um yeah she says according
to shea and the ghost hunter many of the
events depicted on the show were
exaggerated or never happened at all
okay
um
she said she did she would turn around
and see the kitchen cabinets open for no
reason she said that happened on
multiple occasions she did see the
reflection of a figure on her computer
screens that was true uh she said she
had bridger come downstairs now on the
show they just kind of showed him going
barbara brown but like she says he came
down into trance and was laughing
maniacally at her which again that would
probably freak you out yeah um you know
what i mean uh she said she's captured
now this is the ghost hunter talking she
says she's captured miss like forms on
camera and is heard uh booming like
someone walking around upstairs um
she said she was lying on the couch one
night and heard someone murmuring in her
ear
so there's that
says many records about the house were
destroyed when the local library burned
down others are still held by the family
owned the house for several generations
uh been a stagecoach stop a saloon and a
jail and a little boy did fall out of
the upstairs window and the civil war
cemetery behind the house
and uh the ghost hunter said while she
was there and interviewing uh jamie shay
said she was interviewing the kitchen
table and they turned around in the cat
one of the cabinet doors was open so
there's that
uh
yeah so let's see
uh
i think that might be oh uh somebody
said too that they saw like a weird
three-dimensional shadow a
three-dimensional shadow sort of
floating below the ceiling
made a sweeping outward motion on both
sides as if to create the shape of
shoulders and it quickly disappeared
back into the ceiling okay so that's
something else everything that they're
the phenomenon that they're describing
actually is consistent with poltergeist
activity yeah but there doesn't seem to
be a poltergeist focus in other words
there doesn't seem to be a
a kid in there or a disturbed person you
know because usually it's about psychic
disturbances
and it's changed hands now the other
people the other people that lived there
did they report this
they didn't live there long but then
they reported yeah i'm not really sure
like i couldn't determine that like
basically all she said was we had
three renters like in it seemed like
less than a year
um which would
which would suggest
yeah which would suggest that there was
either something wrong with that like
the house was haunted or there was
something
uh physically wrong with the house or
there was something physically or there
was something wrong with the people
so
i don't really know
but to go in there myself and look at it
like i said i don't know if they still
live there because like that was a long
time ago that they wrote this and i
couldn't really find anything more
recent than that she didn't write a book
or anything like that like i said we had
a lot more info about dark wrath because
that lady wrote a book but
this one didn't have a book written
about it or anything and i don't think
that house is particularly famous
other than
you know it being on a haunting so they
did write an article about it like
around halloween one year but that was
around the same time as the haunting
episode came out yeah so it doesn't
really seem i couldn't find anything
like newer than that if somebody can
then let me know i mean they use their
real names on the show yeah it's jamie
shay
uh and it's j-a-i-m-e which is uh the
same way my cousin spells it
s-h-e-a
and the husband's name is ben
and uh they used all their and like i
said it's lamar arkansas i don't know
what the address is
but um
it's definitely in lamar arkansas so if
you know you could probably find it
the physical phenomena that they
described stacking the coins you know
what i mean the the uh
three-dimensional kind of shapes and
figures not figures but you know blobs
or balls or
mists and shapes
things moving
sounds phantom sounds
crashing booming
music that's interesting [ __ ] murmur
murmuring voices that does that doesn't
necessarily mean haunting
you know that
can also mean poltergeist which is rspk
recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis it's
usually from an unknowing
focus that's doing it their kind of
nightmare dream world is acting out in a
recurrently and spontaneously
uh their subconscious minds kind of
making phenomenon that's very ghostly
but it's coming from within
it's someone who is strong with the dark
side of the fourth
uh for the star wars terms
now steve
said that steve mara who's we've jenny's
written some books with him and he's
he's been on a few times yeah he's a
parapsychologist yeah he's a
british parapsychologist we've worked
with
he said that there are some haunting
cases that he's looked at the kind of
merge they're kind of halfway in between
haunting
and poltergeist in other words the the
phenomenon is very physical it does
things it moves things it makes noises
uh there's apparitions
but there is some kind of a disembodied
spirit per se
sometimes it seems to be many of them
but you know this is all theoretical
nobody's gotten down the bottom of it
i had a near-death experience at an
out-of-body experience too
when it was out of body
it was weird you know it was like i was
in a slightly
offset into a slightly different
dimension where i could see the room but
everything was just colors like energy
there was another guy in the room with
me just he just looked like a black
shadow kind of blotting out the
background i could see him moving but he
wasn't defined like a
he wasn't even a humanoid shape it was
just a cloud
i was aware of that
far away from me kind of like in lower
energy dimensions and in higher higher
energy dimensions this [ __ ] sounds
[ __ ] hokey and [ __ ] me saying it i
sound airy fairy kind of like a hippie
sound and [ __ ] but uh
kind of like i was aware that in other
frequencies that there were other
things that were alive or kind of alive
but i didn't see him
um
so
things that had never lived
at least a material world so like i
guess you could say for the one of a
better better word be like angelic
beings
we were real old and wise i could kind
of feel their existence like like
through uh kind of like an internet like
a you know kind of you hook up with it
your awareness is a lot different when
you're having an out-of-body experience
and uh
i was aware that in higher realms they
were kind of like angelic beings and
then lower energy slower colder realms
they were kind of things that
demons but not
in the way of that you would think of
them
uh
they were not
intelligent
sentient or fully sentient fully formed
beings that were well-rounded they were
like a fragment
of somebody's bad mood
running around they were kind of like
the the insects or the cockroaches of
the spiritual world they weren't
spiritual cockroaches they're like a
cockroach that sounds like a good bad
name yeah
yeah
and so
this idea of
some kind of a demon or a ghost like a
grim reaper and a bunch of angry people
um
infesting coming through a portal and
another dimension and infest in the
house i don't really doesn't really jive
up with what i personally saw in an
out-of-body experience
it might seem like that's what it is but
to a person who's in this dimension
but probably more likely what it is
is that there is some stuff in the lower
plains of existence i guess would be a
good way to describe it there are some
things bleeding over in that area
because that area if to use like star
wars terminology that area would be is
strong with the dark side
maybe something bad happened there
so
dark
bad energies can kind of these bad
little insect things that i'm talking
about can kind of make themselves known
but they're not full formed people from
what i experienced they're fragments of
people or fragments of things or
fragments of things that happened in the
past kind of like
in the shining
remember how um
mr halloran says bad things happen and
it can leave behind the traces of itself
like burn toast
that's what we're talking about
the ghosts of those people aren't there
they've moved on but pieces of what
happened to them might be still around
that's that fits in more
with
with the kind of dimension that i saw
briefly
that's probably what it is
just this place that was strong with the
dark side
if you go in there you might see things
that happened in the past or
things little little cockroaches running
around here appear you know
and do do things and say things and make
noises but that's all it is there isn't
any any more to it it's like an echo of
the past
fragment
that's probably what it is i'd like to
go look at it though see if anything
happens
yeah i mean this is actually this is a
good episode this is a creepy episode i
don't know you know i don't know if i
believe it or not but
i don't know if i really go yourself i
don't yeah i don't know if i really
believe any of these but they are fun
and entertaining you watch
and like i said
the people on there because sometimes i
don't know like every now and then
sometimes you get like some of the shows
where
i'm not entirely sure i believe the
people because i think maybe they've got
some problems
um but these people seemed pretty normal
uh you know and they seemed to believe
what they were saying yeah so i
experienced what i experienced you've
seen some of the stuff that i
experienced i interpreted it the way
that i interpreted it and made sense to
me the way i
rationalize it but it i may be wrong
yeah so you know but i'm just going it's
just feeling you know and
when you have an out-of-body experience
it's not dream like it's hyper realistic
hyper realism but it's
like a
like a virtual reality type of situation
with
the dimension isn't that stable i mean
you just look at a place and you go
there you just look it's hard to even
stay still
and you're kind of non-local you can be
in two places at once
uh which is you know we didn't evolve to
to be that way yeah i mean we evolved to
be in a body you're used to that you
know
it's weird so
to use language you guys might
understand the spirit world does not
play by normal physical rules or laws of
nature like time space or mass energy
it's different
it's more like just information and
points of view and perspective
so
yeah something like this theoretically
based on what i saw could happen it's
just that it's more like an illusion it
did happen you are hearing that
but those people aren't there
it's just traces of some things from the
past
guamo khan says classic uh this matinee
has so much classic 13 o'clock energy
lmao we're talking about the shining
steve mara and the haunting yeah yeah
right we're going back to the roots
going back to the roots of this well i
don't know why but like when i read
the thing in
this woman's diary thing about the dimes
like finding dimes in her shoes and in
the bed and stuff i don't know why that
stuck with me i guess because of this
you've seen it happen to me well because
of the the [ __ ] that happened to you
like with the with the towels at the at
the
mammoth mountain place and also when we
had the the ship flying like the uh the
remote flying around we also had like
that stack of coins that showed up like
i stood up my hair was [ __ ] stuck i
had here then and i just thought that
was kind of funny
and and and they're looking gonna be all
right tom do it again do it again
demetrius tell me to do it again and i
looked down at my at my my feet and at
the at the front of my right toes a
stack of coins that high that had not
been there before they weren't there and
they were from the bedroom
because i said this should do something
like bring me uh
make me rich bring me some money it did
bring me money brought me my own money
well it's like that wasn't exactly what
i did but thanks anyway
bring me like some big stacks of cash
yeah this is what i meant for you a
stack of coins probably it's like your
money here's your money
it's like yeah thanks i already had that
but that was your money your
garage door open in the middle of the
night uh doorbell rang in the middle of
the night
um
uh
well i said gosh inner garage door
opening that was the weirdest thing
about that because well because the
thing about it was like the garage door
opening i mean you could
conceivably explain that away because i
know like so you know we had the garage
door opener and it's like i know other
people have them and they're on that
frequency and you can go around opening
other people's garage doors
theoretically
but when that happened one night and i
think it was like three or four in the
morning
the garage door opened and then we were
like what the [ __ ] because it's loud and
so this was at the old house by the way
and so then we
go out and there was like in the laundry
room like this door into the garage and
when we were going to check on it the
door from the laundry room to the garage
went
like by itself and i was like what the
[ __ ] that door does not do that
that door will not wouldn't stay open
actually it didn't open that way and
that was more recent stuff that was
nothing compared to when i was a kid
when i was a kid it was a lot more
intense it would be happening every few
minutes when i was really on a roll and
then uh in that same time i got up that
one morning and saw beijing standing in
the middle of the the living room
looking out the back like what the [ __ ]
and i look and see what she's looking at
in the back doors wide open the back
patio door over there back patio was
wide it was that we never opened that
because there's so there was like four
doors right there well and it was wide
open and the dead bolt and the deadbolt
was still still engaged
and i'm like how long has that been open
and it with the air conditioner was
going and it was cool so it had to have
been seconds that it was only well i saw
it
well the reason that you got up and saw
it was because i saw it when i got up to
go to work oh is that what it was you
said what's that i got up to go to work
and beijing was sitting there looking at
it and i was like what the [ __ ] like
because i saw it was i was like we never
ever opened that patio door ever i think
the only time we opened it was when we
were like when we were painting that
room or something like that that was the
only time we ever or when we were moving
something we never opened that
and like i said the deadbolt was still
like stick like that far out and i was
like there's just no way and so and yeah
beijing was like what the [ __ ] and i was
like right i was like what the [ __ ] so
then i think i came and woke you up and
i was like why is this [ __ ] door open
did you leave this open it's weird it's
weird yeah and then like uh sometime
later i guess it was a few weeks later i
was [ __ ] cooking or getting ready
getting ready to cook and i just turned
my back on the stove and stepped away i
was getting pissed off over something
and boom bow big crash
and behind me i mean just inches
it threw three wooden statues of horses
down and that was like a
seven foot out
and six foot down probably from where
they're so i don't know how they got
that far away they didn't fall they were
thrown
and then a about a seven or eight foot
long
piece of little weak wooden molding that
was the trim that on the top of the damn
cabinets that was pulled off in a single
stroke and
the nails were still in it and they were
twisted i had to straighten all the
nails out and put it back up there and i
don't know how the hell it pulled that
thing off it was pinking thing i don't
know how it pulled that thing off so
fast without breaking it because it was
just flimsy
wooden molding that's pretty weird put
in there with tacks
and it pulled it out in a single [ __ ]
stroke
and threw it down at me with the with
the um
yeah
i had to [ __ ] go back and look at
that and and go i had to kind of go into
the denial like now that didn't happen
that must have been the air conditioner
because there's a vent near it no man
those [ __ ] those little
nails they were like the little wood
nails they're like tacks you know like
the long skinny
wood nails for trim
um
they're almost like the size of a needle
there was about eight of them
in that piece of wood there's no way you
could have pulled that out
and they were bent
they weren't even straight they were
bent
yeah
that was weird
that was weird well other days the other
day at this house you made my my deep
red poster fall off the wall yeah yeah
yeah this one right yeah yeah i put it
back up i put it in a different spot
that's weird i scooched it over a little
bit yeah but yeah you made that fall i
can do weird [ __ ] sometimes just hear it
here again
and what's funny is it won't break it
very rarely has it broken anything
well it'll just throw it at you it
didn't even really break those wooden
statues
and they had little spindly legs on them
it didn't break them i don't know how
they hit without breaking
yeah because that was a long way they
were wet by the ceiling yeah whatever
has it has a hold of it until it hits
the ground
and it was [ __ ] loud man it sounded
louder than normal when it all [ __ ]
see i didn't see that i was i was that
worried you weren't at home
i was at work when yeah he just told me
about it yeah i did i did see the bent
up nails and stuff yeah
yeah i had to kind of go into nah that
didn't really happen
i had to go into that nope yeah he noped
out and the only well what happened here
recently remember i was looking for was
it the motorcycle key
yeah
and and
that was at the old house no no it was
here oh was it yeah in the little mecca
i was looking for something
and uh i think it was a motorcycle key
you guys remember what it was i think it
was a motorcycle key jumped off at me
off the table oh that's right i thought
you were talking about was with the
tables i thought you were talking about
the old house like several months ago
when you lost the motorcycle key for a
really really long time and again we
looked at the cat had it oh that [ __ ]
freak music we'll see you we now you've
been looking for it for days days
we looked everywhere for the [ __ ]
washing machine dryer we pulled all the
clothes out we pulled all the pockets
out we went through all the laundry we
looked through everything
we couldn't find it and then he's like
you know [ __ ] it it was a motorcycle key
with a damn blue rubber
uh pad yeah on it and he's like and he
finally we had looked at it i think it
was maybe like four or five days we'd
look for it and it was i'm like i have
no [ __ ] idea where that thing we
looked everywhere and uh he was just
like [ __ ] it i'm gonna order another one
yeah and then he's sitting at the end of
the bed watching tv and he looked down
at pookie when i was wrestling with
pookie yeah it's wrestling pookie and i
looked up at the tv
and then as i looked down i saw her
catch something like that and she's
biting it like that and i look and she
she had the cake in her hands in her
body i was like what
i didn't see it happening i guess it's
like it materialized out of thin air and
dropped off she was like a toy for me i
saw it at the corner of my eye or
grabbed something and then started
she went uh yeah they started chewing on
this rubber yeah she's chewing and
kicking it with her back legs
yeah she wasn't that at all she was just
like
my hair stood up a toy appeared he got
me it got me it got me and i ran in
there and showed it to jenny
i mean we had that place upset we had
torn that [ __ ] house up looking for
that [ __ ] look at that beale key
and it was only when you said [ __ ] it
i'm ordering a a spare they gave it back
and then
well they gave it to pookie yeah give it
to pookie
it's funny
oracle said i'm not surprised pookie is
amazing after all yeah
she manifested the key yeah
all right so we've been going more than
an hour like i said we've been going on
longer than the actual episode yeah but
that's how we do that's how we do when
we start talking about a haunting you
know what i mean we have a lot of fun
with those so if anybody has any oh
somebody's going to buy a motorcycle or
something um harley yeah it's somebody's
our neighbor um if anybody has any
recommendations for what episode we
should do next monday yeah uh let me
know if you don't have time to do it now
then maybe send me a message on facebook
or
in one of the comments on the other
videos or something like that i mean if
nobody comes up with one we'll just find
one but
preferably the first
four or five seasons because it's the
ones we like the most but if you like
one of the later ones then let us know i
think we have seasons one through well
hold on six or seven blair just says
he's been he's tried to ask me project
for years just gave up that's the
problem don't try
you know you have to stop all thinking
and just allow it's hard man and the
heart and when you know that it's hard
it [ __ ] you up
you have to believe that it's easy
and that and you have to basically will
yourself to die you just stop everything
stop you try to stop all thinking and
just relax
and just allow
allow it to happen
trying
reinstitutes will and
and and consciousness so that stops it
you have to just let go of everything
you gotta you can't have any fear
because it's gonna be basically death
it's an it's a
and you'll feel like you're pulled up
like you're being pulled up into a
higher realm
like you want to gravitate up to where
those angelic beings are it's how it
felt
don't do it you probably won't come back
don't do it okay
but you know
and when you first come out you'll see
look down at yourself you won't be able
to stand still you'll be all over the
place and if you just think of something
you'll appear over there and then you
freak out you'll you'll vanish and you
wake up back in the body
kwama khan says hashtag bring back the
where is that raccoon sound bite
where's that raccoon oh you know what i
should do like a a gif if i could
finally get then i can like put it in
the show like if i ever remember if we
ever say something that that merits that
i don't want to overdo it but
i feel like we should probably have it
yeah so i can put it in here and like
pop it out when the time when the time
comes
where is that record yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god
now i want to show this just says where
is that hell house
that was yeah okay i remember that i
have that one i think i yeah we have
that one it's the one with the clown
right
is that the one with the clown see i
could like i said they're the titles are
so generic that i can't remember but
yeah so
yeah so we might end up doing that one
uh so we'll see next week
uh yeah probably so i think tomorrow
we're gonna do another matinee we'll
probably do do you want to do death
machine
okay yeah i mean we don't have to i just
i said i think it's free on voodoo so or
i think it's like 299 or 390 to rent it
on amazon prime because you were saying
when we watched a split second that you
kind of wanted to watch death machine so
i don't know or if you change your mind
so maybe it'll be death machine maybe
it'll be something else we'll figure it
out uh but yeah so we will see you guys
again tomorrow talking about another
movie thanks for dropping by this
afternoon and we'll see you later bye